[Música]
momento de la revista de prensa de
directo américa cuando el rosa pérez más
de un saludo para ustedes rosa buenos
días pero no buenas noticias para
comenzar buenos dias angela da
exactamente no pues empezamos a por la
respuesta que finalmente ha dado beijing
a lo que comentaba el inicio del
informativo a estos xinjiang police
papers que al final son una filtración
masiva de documentos que revelan las
condiciones dentro de los llamados
centros o campos de reeducación en
xinjiang en china claro y es que la bbc
el titular de respuesta a la bbc es
bastante fuerte y lo voy a leer pues
para nuestros televidentes la bebé se
prepara un recipiente con agua sucia
para la jefa de derechos humanos de la
onu rosa exactamente no como diciendo
que este reportaje que ha sido publicado
por la bbc entre otros medios de
comunicación este que estamos viendo
aquí es un poco pues el allanamiento del
camino al informe que debe preparar la
alta comisionada de las naciones unidas
para los derechos humanos michelle
bachelet de visita a china en estos
momentos y precisamente una de las cosas
que critica el 'global times' es que
occidente por un lado insiste en conocer
pues la situación de los derechos
humanos en china y que cuando finalmente
la alta comisionada de los derechos
humanos de naciones unidas se desplaza
al territorio pues se critica que no va
a poder tener una visión real y objetiva
pues del panorama no de los derechos
humanos en china sobre todo en esta
región de xinjiang y respecto a las
condiciones de la población we would
recordemos esta minoría musulmana y para
señalarte no algunos de los párrafos
bien duros de este editorial del 'global
times' dice hay que reconocer que cuando
se trata de inventar mentiras sobre
xinjiang los medios de comunicación y
los políticos occidentales se han vuelto
muy competentes en la en la cooperación
entre ellos y acusan a adrián senin que
fue quien filtró a todos estos
documentos a los medios de comunicación
obtenidos por una fuente anónima pues es
digamos está motivado políticamente
contra china al igual que la bbc es todo
según el global times que también apunta
que varios de sus reporteros se han
desplazado a la región a la región de
xinjiang en los últimos años y han hecho
entrevistas in situ y que personas que
supuestamente estaban muertas o
desaparecidas para los medios
occidentales estaban en realidad vivas y
viviendo su vida tranquilamente y que lo
que pues los medios occidentales
consideran centros de detención en
realidad son escuelas instituciones
gubernamentales hospitales residencias
tiendas etcétera bueno sea como sea pues
les animamos a ir a ver este reportaje
tan completo en la página web de la bbc-
rápido cambio de tema de rosa carolina
polonia escribe en el huffington post'
sobre la noticia que nos tiene en luto
desde hace dos días el costo de los
simulacros de tiroteo masivo en las
escuelas para la salud mental de los
alumnos y de los profesores exactamente
no porque este aumento de los tiroteos
masivos ha llevado en que a que en el
curso 2005-2006 fueran un 40 por ciento
de las escuelas públicas de eeuu
que realizaban simulacros de situaciones
en las que había un atacante que
perpetraba un tiroteo masivo o que
llevaba una bomba a que este número de
escuelas que hacen este tipo de
simulacros aumentara al 95% en la
actualidad y claro pues muchos expertos
se plantean cuál es el coste psicológico
de vivir este tipo de situaciones
traumáticas tanto para los alumnos como
para los profesores y según un estudio
del instituto tecnológico de georgia
este tipo pues de situaciones provoca un
aumento del 42% en el estrés y la
ansiedad un aumento del 39% en la
depresión y un aumento del 23% en los
problemas de salud fisiológica en niños
desde los 5 años hasta los estudiantes
de secundaria maestros y padres y bien
este tema es bien complejo porque hay
distintos maestros que participaron en
este estudio señalan que los alumnos en
el momento de estar en este simulacro
recordemos que son simulacros escribían
a sus padres erre sábana lloraban porque
pensaban que iban a morir de verdad los
padres notaron también que sus hijos
después de someterse a este tipo de
simulacros
al escuchar por ejemplo una alarma de
incendios reaccionaban de forma
exagerada también pues el doctor jones
él
del hospital pediátrico de los ángeles
señala que el impacto varía según el
niño pero que someterse a este
simulacros y está sádicos discusiones
recurrentes sobre los tiroteos pues
implica la expectativa de que finalmente
estas situaciones pueden ocurrir y de
que el mundo es pues un lugar inseguro y
que esto determina su relación pues con
el entorno y solo angela pues una cosa
bien importante y es que hay distintos
expertos que señalan que los simulacros
que tienen un alto nivel de realismo con
pintura de sangre ficticia etcétera pues
que finalmente no son útiles porque dice
que el estrés y la ansiedad pueden
comprometer significa significativamente
la atención el aprendizaje y la memoria
y que al final pues uno a pesar de haber
vivido un simulacro puede no saber cómo
reaccionar ante una situación real
pues bien rosadas sin palabras sin
palabras y aún así se realiza dentro de
poco en houston el congreso nacional del
rifle gracias a ustedes y vamos a
cambiar de tema porque viene ya nuestro
invitado del día